it's incredible to have um a best friend
like that guy
he's an amazing person blake shelton
officially popped the question
and gwen stefani has two words for him
yes please
tell me i'm not the luckiest guy et has
learned that blake and gwen
got engaged the week of october 17th in
blake's home state
oklahoma on tuesday gwen posted this
adorable photo on
instagram kissing her fiance and
showing off her new bling her caption
gwen's answer to blake's proposal
yes please the country's superstar also
announced the exciting news on his page
writing hey gwen stefani thanks for
saving my 2020
and the rest of my life don't you just
love love blake also added
i love you i heard a yes how would you
say
gwen makes you a better man oh my god i
don't i can't remember
i don't want to remember what i was like
before
gwen actually if that answers your
question gwen and blake's famous friends
shared lots of love in the comment
section their fellow voice coach
john legend wrote amazing
congratulations to you both
dua lipa also sent her best wishes and
hilariously alluded to her interview
with gwen on jimmy kimmel live in august
writing i guess our little interview
aged well
so i had that you've been spending
quarantine with your husband blake
shelton well he's not my husband
but but that sounded cool when you said
it um no
the pair started dating in late 2015 and
have been
inseparable ever since any time i can be
around blake
is is you know a blessing so as much
time as possible
they've appeared side by side as coaches
on the voice and
their chemistry on stage is undeniable
i'm thankful for gwen for tons of
reasons but mostly
just because she makes us all
look a whole lot better on that show and
blake and gwen share the same passions
like music collaborating on their song
nobody like you
[Music]
gwen was crying when we even just talked
about
singing it together at all you know and
it just seemed to fit perfectly with
with her
our story yeah and and musically i think
it walks the line of what i can do and
what she can do and it just
everything just kind of aligned and came
together and it's one of those once in a
lifetime
you know moments
[Music]